on prime crime kayla it seemed like she
was getting paranoid towards
friday the case of a missing woman that
had authorities baffled
what's your thoughts there's more to the
story multiple theories arise
as a private investigator you have
skills to not be seen
i had a lot of different characters that
you know were persons of interest at
some points
and the evidence that tells a different
story
what we're all doing out there thus far
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases a woman
disappears and the question becomes not
only what happened
but is someone responsible on september
8
2017 in pensacola florida 33 year old
taylor wright
suddenly goes missing i think i would
send her a text every now and then
didn't get any response i was just
trying to start careful conversation
i text taylor a couple more times no
responses
wright's disappearance really didn't
make any sense she had been living with
her girlfriend cassandra waller
and had a son from a previous marriage
interestingly though
wright was a private investigator as a
private investigator you have skills
to not be seen just like an undercover
role with a police officer
so it would have been very easy for her
to disappear
did wright disappear on her own or did
someone
do something to her investigators start
looking
into several people cassandra as an
alternative
suspect was another place that the
police would reasonably look
waller would explain that wright had
cheated on her
whenever i found out about uh taylor
like kind of having this relationship
that she didn't end with this other girl
and i told taylor to get all my life and
everything and she kept begging and
texting me please just like hear me out
meet me at ash's house and
you know 5 30 the next day she's like
i'll confess everything to like you and
ash
and i thought it was a little weird that
she wanted ash there but at the same
time i was like good you know friends
gonna know what you did their friends
gonna know
you know like the shadiness that you
that you might contain within you
at one point wright's friend ashley
macarthur is brought in for questioning
i wouldn't think so not only does she
talk about wright's relationship with
waller
but she mentions something very
interesting about
wright's ex-husband jeff wright the
story that i get is that jeff was the
aggressive one
and that he was the one that would be
you know
like volatile and violent with her i
know she was trying to hide money
from the just situation at the time of
her disappearance
wright and her ex were in an apparent
legal battle over the custody of their
son
the way that she put everything to me
was like she was just
trying to get her life together to get
her kid
to get back on her feet and that jeff
had done so much
you know to her to take away all of this
money that she had and everything else
in fact according to macarthur wright
even withdrew money from a bank account
she shared with jeff
and entrusted the cash with macarthur
she didn't want
her name or anything to be on anything
that jeff could find
so i was like we'll just keep it and
give it to you or whatever it's common
practice
in divorce proceedings especially when
they're tumultuous
for a spouse to want to hide money and
we know that the money was withdrawn
from taylor's account and we know a
cashier's check
was given and handed over and deposited
into macarthur's account
cassandra and jeff two people with close
connections to wright
seem like viable suspects in the case
anytime we have a homicide
you know obviously a significant other a
spouse a girlfriend a boyfriend
is always kind of you know a person of
interest
but once you know we were able to talk
to jeff ray we were able to talk to
taylor's girlfriend
i think it was clear that they had
absolutely no involvement
but who else would have a motive to harm
right
so taylor it seemed like she was getting
paranoid
towards friday she was talking about how
she felt like something just wasn't
right with ashley
there are three important things to
remember with ashley macarthur
first it was revealed that wright had
wanted her money back
taylor's been trying to get the money
out of ash's safety deposit box
taylor said for like four or five days
it actually kept making up excuses and
everything
second on the day of her disappearance
macarthur said she drove
right to the bank to get the money she
was like okay well ash is coming over
we're gonna go to ash's bank we're gonna
pick up my money and stuff out of the
safety deposit box
ash had pulled up we hugged we kissed
said love you
and three ashley macarthur a crime scene
technician
is believed to be the last person to see
right
before she vanished
i don't believe taylor's been harmed
i just i think taylor's doing what
taylor does
i think her behavior in the
interrogation was enough
to raise eyebrows she did not behave in
a way that would be consistent with
someone who had empathy for
the victim
i'm stuck with all of her stuff and my
office
just trying to help her and of course
the story that i get is a very
sob story about how jeff's taking all
this money
and now she's just you know trying to
hide it and move it and do
all kind of just shady stuff with it
she also behaved in a way that i believe
was cavalier
she seemed to be making jokes and really
putting
down the character of the victim
which is not a good look when you are
genuinely concerned about someone who is
supposed to be your friend
i do think macarthur's behavior in the
interrogation room was suspicious
in that we noticed that she was talking
in the past
tense of her friend i didn't know who
she was
until a lot of this because what i knew
her to be was
one thing and now what i'm finding out
is
something totally different at one point
macarthur's then boyfriend is brought in
for an interview
and he provides quite the insight into
this woman
how well do you trust ashley i don't
trust her at all
you don't trust her with your freedom no
hell no
i'll catch her into their lives does
macarthur know more than she's letting
on
when we return
[Music]
she's always carrying weapons whether
it's knives or
guns or whatever
she's not an easy target in 2017
private investigator taylor wright goes
missing investigators learned that on
the day of her disappearance
wright had been hanging out with her
friend ashley macarthur who's believed
to be the last person to see her
macarthur appears to suggest that wright
isn't in danger
she was fine she just said that she
wanted to go have a beer and that she
was gonna get an uber to take her to go
have a beer
when macarthur is interviewed she says
that wright had asked her to hold on to
some money of hers
as wright was in the middle of a divorce
from her ex-husband
text messages reveal though that wright
needed that money back
macarthur claims on the day right
disappeared she returned the cash
and wright carried it off in a duffel
bag
your feelings on all this missing person
and her talking to you
what's your thoughts there's more to the
story i don't know if she's pointless
said they are not going to find her she
took that money into that
what do you think about that don't make
no sense i'm drawing a little kid
while macarthur appeared to be
forthcoming about details
something just didn't seem quite right
would you mind if we if we
what's it called don't the phone
intrinsically examine your phone yes
we don't look at
ashley's first police interrogation was
um kind of annoying to be honest with
you i mean i felt like she was kind of
giggly
she was kind of giddy she was almost
kind of flirty with law enforcement
her second interview was completely
different her body language is different
her tone of voice was different she was
definitely much more somber
you know she probably knew at that point
she was she was in some trouble
you know we've turned up some things
that we don't
we don't really know what to think at
this point
law enforcement discovered that
macarthur had deposited 34
000 of wright's money into her own
personal bank account
and they believe she hadn't kept it for
safekeeping
we found some some bank records that
drew some questions can you tell me
anything about you
and taylor in any sort of
involvement with any businesses i
believe ashley mcarthur killed
taylor wright taylor wright needed her
money back
and it was gone ashley had spent it all
macarthur's then boyfriend even suggests
her financial situation
was a bit curious the girl spends money
on everybody around me
yeah everybody it's not uncommon for her
to spend money on everybody
however it would be argued that
macarthur was just a generous person
didn't have any money problems and
didn't need wright's money
macarthur even defended herself what
happened to this money after you
um deposited lot of it i used because it
was payment for
the money that i had been given
then there was the matter of what
macarthur says she and wright did
the day of wright's disappearance she
claimed that after returning wright's
money the two had gone horseback riding
at her family's farm
went back to macarthur's house and then
right left
macarthur says she never saw her again
when we started
plotting all the phone calls that you
and taylor we're making that day
um there are some discrepancies and what
you told us
the records indicated that the day after
wright went missing
wright's phone pinged off of a tower
near a wedding in alabama
a wedding attended by macarthur
the cell phone tower evidence is very
important and now we always have to
remember that cell phone records are not
a smoking gun it is always left up to
interpretation
but the cell phone records later showed
she was actually texting from the same
location
that the defendant was located when they
supposedly according to the defendant
were not together at that time is it
possible that macarthur had wright's
phone
after she vanished let's go back to
cassandra waller where she describes the
text conversation she had with wright
on the night of her disappearance 758
taylor sent me that text
when i'm mad at you i should have called
i just need some time to think
um i'm trying to get my life organized
and back on track
at like 11 54 11 55
ash text me a screenshot of what taylor
just sent her the text that i told you
where taylor says ash a message saying
i'm okay i'm not doing anything bad i'm
just stressed out with the move in court
and i need a few days to myself it's
actually a common practice for somebody
who murders somebody to pretend that
person is still alive
by communicating with family members
to make believe that they had run off
somewhere and disappeared
but what trips them up is the pinging
and cell tower
location services that they're able to
pick up even the texts themselves are
not the same type of
words or verbiage that is normally used
by the person who has gone missing or
disappeared
the cell phone tower records revealed
something else as well
we know that you didn't go to milton
when you said you went to walton
not when you said you weren't there
you went that evening what were y'all
doing out there this farm
i know y'all were there we picked up
some
stuff that taylor had there that you
know that she would store
um
you need to tell us where she is
up next we finally learn what happened
to taylor wright
i think something happened and you're
trying to forget about it personally
okay
[Music]
where is she at i don't know where she's
where's her body at i don't know where
she is
she's dead though
in 2017 taylor wright vanishes and now
authorities believe
her friend crime scene investigator
ashley macarthur is behind it
financial records indicate that
macarthur may have stolen wright's money
and cell phone tower data appears to
show that not only had macarthur been
using
wright's phone but the two had visited
macarthur's family farm
on the night of wright's disappearance
so you're the only one that was with her
on this day at this farm that you did
not disclose to us
i didn't do anything did you say this if
she's at that farm we're gonna find her
because we're executing a search warrant
out there right now
it's that search of macarthur's family
property that finally reveals
what happened to wright the missing
woman's remains are found
a skull with a bullet hole buried in a
shallow grave
ashley macarthur is then arrested and
would later be charged
with first degree premeditated murder
what i believe happened is on september
8th of 2017
ashley picked taylor up under the guise
of going to this bank to get taylor
wright's money
i believe at some point during their
time together ashley probably made up
some excuse as to why
she needed to go out to this family
property that was
you know kind of out in the middle of
nowhere and i believe taylor went
along for the ride and i believe once
they got out to this area which is a
huge piece of property
i believe ashley shot taylor in the back
of the head
yet is macarthur the killer no dna
or murder weapon could be linked to her
it also couldn't be determined
when wright died lack of dna lack of an
actual weapon or smoking gun and
moreover lack of an actual certain time
of death
is a strong indicator that it may not be
the person that you think it is
maybe ashley macarthur though could get
away with the perfect murder
as a crime scene investigator she would
have the tools of
knowing exactly what to look for the
forensics dna
trace evidence looking for a murder
weapon
anything that was in the vicinity that
the police would be able to use and
photograph
for later identification then
there was the home depot footage
wright's remains had been covered with
concrete and potting soil
which authorities say macarthur can be
seen buying
the day after wright went missing just
a coincidence they were doing the
work around their house a rain tree not
only in the basement but in there with
some yard work going on and a new deck
had recently been built
the state had all this time and they
made no
effort to do any type of forensic
testing of this to say yes this is
exactly the same potting soil because
they knew the brand
this is exactly the same concrete i have
no question
that the concrete ashley macarthur
purchased at home depot is the same
concrete that was put
around it taylor wright's body coming up
does the state have enough to convict
macarthur
state of florida versus ashley britt
macarthur
verdict as to the charge in count one
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all
good evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't
really jump to conclusions welcome to
prime crime tonight
another day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original
and compelling programming the law on
crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box
this is law and crime
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father
guilty or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before get caught
in providence
[Music]
tell us what happened i think at this
point i need an attorney
because it seems to me that you all
think that i did something to her
in 2019 ashley macarthur is on trial for
the murder of her friend
taylor wright wright's decomposed
remains were found on a property
belonging to macarthur's family the
government alleges that macarthur killed
wright
over greed this defendant was supposed
to be
holding taylor's money not spending it
taylor needed that money back and that
money was gone
and the day taylor was with his
defendant to get her money back
then taylor was gone prosecuting the
ashley mcarthur case was
it was extremely difficult she didn't
look like the typical
type of person that's going to go murder
somebody
i had a lot of different characters that
you know were
persons of interest at some point for me
it was
concerning and and difficult to make
sure that i could piece it all together
to paint a clear picture that ashley
macarthur was in fact guilty of
murdering taylor wright
macarthur's attorneys pointed to the
fact that there was no solid evidence
tying their client to the death of
wright the evidence will show you
the state's case is built on yes lies
told by ashley mcarthur
a motive she may have had
things that she did ways that she lived
her life
that you may not like but their case
will not be
built on eyewitness testimony it will
not be built on physical evidence
or scientific evidence circumstantial
evidence cases on murders are the
hardest to prove
and you need a combination of a series
of circumstantial events
in order to put the case together she
was the last person
seen with her she was reported missing
her cell phone was with her
the fact that we have video evidence of
her buying concrete and potting soil
prior to that and knowing the way that
we found the body
and also when the police officers were
able to trip her up
and catch her in a lie we knew
macarthur's statements to police got her
in trouble
but what we didn't expect was what she
also allegedly told
others prior to wright's death what did
ashley say to you
about taylor that night the world would
be a better place without taylor
after hearing all the evidence and
deliberating for a little over two
hours the jury made their decision
we the jury find the defendant ashley
macarthur guilty of first degree
premeditated murder with a firearm as
charged in the indictment i think the
initial feeling when the jury returns a
verdict of guilty is
just it's an overwhelming sense of
relief
of comfort certainly there's a level of
gratitude for the you know toward the
jurors for for doing such a great job
um and then of course there's always a
feeling of justice for the victim and in
this case for taylor wright
you know obviously we're very
disappointed i mean we
we put years of preparation into this
and you know we thought we had built a
good defense
obviously ms jensen did a great job she
had a lot of really good evidence on her
side but disappointed
i'm going to sentence you to life with a
mandatory minimum 25 years
state prison when i look back on the
ashley macarthur case
i think about taylor wright and i think
about her son
and how they're missing out on each
other's lives i was there when taylor
came into this world
and i'm here today taylor was taken too
early
and she was not taken through an act of
god or through illness
she was taken through human behavior
that was very cruel
and i could go on but it's just such a
tragic story
pretty scary to think about the murder
of taylor wright when you consider it
was one of her closest friends who
betrayed her but as clever and
resourceful as macarthur seemingly
thought she was in covering up her crime
it was investigators in the jury who saw
right through it
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
prime crime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you